j'adore faire la cuisine ça me relaxe
énormément de librairies important dans
les libraires indépendants
c'est vrai qu'on est une des plus
importantes à montréal et puis que je
suis toute petite j'allais magazine avec
ma mère ma grand mère pour acheter ces
schémas chaud que ce soit la mode les
livres ou la bouffe leur petit univers
dont hannu quartier leur couleur leur
saveur mais en ces jours de marc hecker
nombreux sont les petits commerçants qui
ont l'âme tourmentée et le tiroir-caisse
inquiet ça tu l'habitude des gens de
venir
pour nous ça nous fait beaucoup de tort
on n'est pas certains passent au travers
ces cultures extraordinairement
difficile
la côte des neiges à montréal c'est la
deuxième fois en cinq ans qu'on y vend
entre la rue quand ils ont fait des très
gros travaux sur côte des neiges qui
devait durer trois mois qui ont duré un
an et demi ils n'ont jamais fait en même
temps les trottoirs et qu'on en finisse
une fois pour toute et la chaussée donc
c'était catastrophique
on a eu des travaux en 2012 j'espère
2012 la et demi on a perdu un demi
million de chiffre d'affaires cette fois
ci les commerçants ray bien souhaité que
la ville pense un peu plus à eux
il a fallu qu'on soit on a une rencontre
pour exiger que ça se fasse aussi
pendant les vacances de la construction
parce que la ville avait pas prévu que
le mois le plus fort d'activité dans le
quartier ici c'était pas l'été comme au
centre-ville parce que les touristes
c'est en septembre parce qu'il ya des
écoles des collèges et des universités
frustration et bien sûr inquiétude pour
le presque 40 employés chez les
librairies les travaux mettent en péril
comme ça notre capacité à recouvrir nos
humiliations à quelques pas de la
librairie ou restaurants de nadaï de son
ami robert évidemment la terrasse est
déserte
tous les touristes tous les passants
parce qu'après tout c'est une rue très
passante donc c'est cette partie de de
clientèle que nous avons carrément vu
disparaître depuis le début de l'été ça
tue un quartier il peut y avoir un petit
geste de la ville de montréal vis-à-vis
des taxes ou je ne sais pas n'importe
quoi pour les commerçants mais on
s'entend dire ouais nous vous allez en
profiter
hello ya aucune mesure de compensation
on a prévu relié au prévôt plein
allègements de taxes on prévoit pas de
l'aide pour la durée des travaux on
prévoit pas comme ça s'est fait dans
d'autres villes
autre rue autre chantier redouté des
travaux de 14 millions $ qui vont durer
un an vont commencer en septembre rue
saint denis entre du luth et marianne où
se trouve la boutique de véronique
d'aragon c'est la fri samedi dans un
mois alors qu'elle lancera sa collection
d'automne
elle aura de nouveaux voisins des gros
camions qui va le traîner tout petit job
à fait clair quelques années un gros
camion de stationner devant ma porte
dont la voix plus l'industrie
le passant achète ce qui est dans la
vitrine
la question c'est est-ce que ça va
déborder le temps qu'ils ont prévu
pis on le sait pas c'est un gros point
d'interrogation on n'a pas l'impression
que la ville travaille avec les
commerçants on prend les commerçants
pour acquis on reprend les commerçants
comme une espèce de deux choses
secondaires alors que c'est ce qui fait
que la ville de montréal que les vielles
moral elle est ce qu'elle est une
connerie vivante que mary et habitat
qu'on a envie du mais combien de temps
ça va durer
difficile à dire sur le boulevard
saint-laurent des travaux interminables
ont presque tué l'activité commerciale
et cet exemple là il y pense tous sûrs
qu des neiges saint denis ou ailleurs